yes, thank you very much.
i would also like to welcome you warmly.
My name is Sherwin hachsheno
and I have not been a to this day.
within the framework of today's founding meeting
I was elected deputy chairman of the party
chosen.
in my person,
am 48 years old,
born in tierarn and live since my 10.
.
Year of life in Germany.
as a lateral entrant
I bring 25 years of professional experience with me.
on the one hand "Out of the economy
through leadership duties in a
international construction group
and build up its own company,
on the other hand From science
through his work as a university professor.
Wolfgang Tiere once said,
democracy is our most valuable good.
to maintain them is both a task and an obligation.
that's why I'm here today.
let's take a look at the voter turnout and polls,
it is that in the next federal election
less than 50 percent
of eligible voters cast their ballots for one of the
so-called democratic
parties of the center will be submitted.
the majority
has confidence in these established parties
lost.
also trust in the media
unfortunately takes more and more AB.
for me,
these are alarming developments,
which poses a serious threat
represent for the continuation of our democracy.
and I too have in the past few years
Trust lost.
but it is not a marked disappointment,
but the fact,
that concrete
policy objectives
are no longer represented in a credible manner.
would like to state some points,
that made me
own biography very move.
Example, foreign policy.
so someone who has memory of it,
as a child in a country
to grow up by having 1 war,
I am.
shakes that our foreign and security policy
is increasingly focused on it,
that our country,
that Germany
is increasingly involved in military operations,
rather than through diplomati and relaxation policy
our influence in the world for peace
to make apply.
just with our history
we have a great responsibility.
Example education policy,
when my parents came to Germany,
start here from the beginning,
we lived on social assistance for many years.
later I made the very formative experience,
that social advancement through integration
and is possible through education.
today we have it not only with a failure
in integration policy
but also with a dilapidated education system,
manifests social injustice
and also accelerates the shortage of skilled workers.
Example of economic and labor market policy,
I know From my own experience,
that good framework conditions for our industry,
for medium-sized businesses,
for the many self-employed,
but also fair löne and safe jobs 2
Pages of the same medal are.
many entrepreneurs
are committed to the responsibility for their employees
very aware,
unlike anonymously managed large corporations or
global financial investors.
it is not a contradiction,
advocate for the interests of the many
hardworking people in our country
and for good economic conditions
to use.
most people just want to,
that their government
does not pursue any ideologies,
but simply makes a rational policy,
that improves their living conditions
and that things are fair again in our country.
I know that there are many people,
who have their hopes in our alliance for this very reason
set.
as a civil engineer and entrepreneur
I am not alien to building up anew.
I am therefore very pleased,
that I
may bring in my experience at this point,
to support.
and I want to contribute to a political culture,
in which people like to engage in democracy.
ladies and gentlemen,
you can imagine,
that today's step
was not an easy decision for me.
but i am deeply convinced of this,
that we need a new force in Germany,
that gives people confidence,
that politics is representing their interests again
and at the same time strengthens democracy.
and I am also convinced that the new party
with its
orientation will be successful.
that's when I decided,
no longer to stand on the sidelines,
but to take me to the square.
thank you very much!